All right, we are on
problem number 17.
I think my pen is too thick.
There you go.
We were on problem 17, and I
think I did a good job of
confusing you at the end
of the last video.
So I'm going to, to some degree,
start from scratch.
So I've left what I drew last
time where we had this graph
that they did on problem 17.
And they said that this is the
graph of y equals f of x.
And they said, which of the
following could be used to get
the graph of y is equal
to f of x plus 2?
So they want us to graph,
essentially, y is equal to f
of x plus 2.
And just so we don't get
confused with the y's and
stuff, I'm going to define a
new function called g of x.
Hopefully this will not confuse
you and just simplify
some things.
And I'll call it g of x is
equal to f of x plus 2.
And I did that because I
didn't want 2 y's here.
I want you to realize that this
is a different function,
and these aren't the same
function or the same y.
So I'm going to define a new
function called g of x is
equal to f of x plus 2.
So first let's just write a
little table that maybe we can
understand a little
bit about f of x.
We know a couple things.
When x is 0, f of x is 1.
When x is 1, f of x is 0.
We know that, right?
So let's do another
table for g of x.
So let's do x, g of x.
So now let's think about it in
a slightly different, almost
in a reverse way.
We know a couple of values.
We know what f of 0 is, right?
We know f of 0, and we
know f of 1, right?
We're given it right here.
We know f of 0 is equal
to 1, and we know f of
1 is equal to 0.
Now what value do I have to
stick into g of x for
x to get f of 0?
Well I said g of x is equal
to f of x plus 2, right?
So to get f of 0, I need to
put a negative 2 in here.
g of negative 2 is equal to f
of minus 2 plus two, which
equals f of 0, right?
So this is g of minus 2.
It's the same thing as f of 0.
And so x is just minus 2.
So when x is minus 2, g of
x is equal to 1, right?
x is minus 2. g of minus 2 is
the same thing as f of 0
because you get the minus 2 plus
2, and that equals one.
So there we go, g of minus
2 is equal to 1.
Then what value do I have to
put into g to get f of 1?
So what do I have to put here
for this expression right here
to be equal to 1?
Well it has to equal negative
1, g of negative 1.
If you put negative 1 into g,
you get negative 1 plus 2,
which is 1.
That's the same thing as f
of 1, so that equals 0.
So when x is at negative 1,
g of negative 1 is 0.
So let's draw g.
When x is equal to-- I'll draw
it in this color-- when x is
negative 2-- so this is negative
2-- we have g of x is
equal to 1.
So this right here is a point.
So this is at negative 2, 0.
And then we also have the
point negative 1, 0.
So we also have this point,
negative 1, 0.
Negative 1, 0 is that point.
And so we see what happened is,
is that g of x is actually
a shift to the left by 2.
So g of x is going to look
something like this.
It's going to look like
the other graph, just
shifted to the left.
Esstentially, we just took the
other graph and we shifted it
to the left.
And we didn't do it with
all the points.
We could have done it with more
points, but we did it
with the two points that we know
definitely are defined
for f of x, right?
And those two points
definitely were
shifted to the left.
This is actually a little
bit complicated.
And a very simple way of
thinking about this problem
is, in general, if I have f of
x, then f of x plus anything--
f of x plus 2 in this case-- is
going to be the same graph
of f of x, except I'm shifting
it to the left.
And it's a little unintuitive
that I'm adding 2, but I'm
shifting to the left.
And the intuition behind that
is, whatever value f of 0 was,
now that's going to happen when
I put a negative 2 in.
So that's the intuition why
you're shifting to the left.
The old 0 is now the
new negative 2.
Similarly, f of x minus 2, if
I wanted to draw that, would
look something like this.
It would go like this.
And it would come down, and
it would go like this.
So that would be shifting
to the right by 2.
And shifting up and down is
actually much easier.
If we have f of x and we want to
shift it up, say by 2, then
we'd have f of x plus 2.
We just change the
y intercept.
Or if we wanted to shift
it down, we'd have
f of x minus 2.
Hopefully I didn't confuse
you with all this jargon.
And the easy way to think about
it is really just what I
told you, you know, this rule.
But I don't want you to
just have the rule.
I want you to, hopefully, have
a little bit of intuition on
how the shifting works.
Let's move on to the
next problem.
Oh, I didn't tell you which
choice that was.
Well if you just shift it to
the left two, it looks like
choice number C.
All right, we're at number 18.
And they have this figure.
This is a triangle.
It's like that.
And then within that, there's
another triangle.
It looks like that.
And then we have A,
B, C, D, E, F.
It says, in the figure above,
AB is equal to BC.
So AB, so this big triangle.
Maybe I'll draw it
in this color.
So this side, AB,
is equal to BC.
So both sides are equal.
Now what does that immediately
tell us?
If we have 2 sides equal,
that means that the
base angles are equal.
That means that this angle
is going to be
equal to this angle.
What else do we know?
And DE is equal to EF
is equal to DF.
So we also know-- I'll switch
colors-- that DE is equal to
EF is equal to DF.
And that immediately
tells us this is
an equilateral triangle.
All the sides are the same,
so all the angles
have to be the same.
So this angle has to be equal to
this angle, which has to be
equal to this angle.
And they're all going
to be 60 degrees.
They're all going to be
equal to 60 degrees.
OK.
Now what else are
they telling us?
If the measure of angle ABC--
so this angle is 30 degrees,
that's what they're telling us--
and the measure of BDE is
50 degrees, so this
is 50 degrees.
They want to know what DFA is.
So we want to figure out
this angle right here.
So this is the angle
game again.
So a couple of things.
If this angle up here is 30,
what are these base angles
going to be?
Well they're going to have to
add up, all of them combined,
add up to 180, right?
So that means that these two are
going to add up to 150--
because you know 180 minus 30--
and they're the same.
So they're the same and
they add up to 150.
They're both going to have
to be 75 degrees.
So that's 75 degrees, and that
is 75 degrees, right?
And then what else do we know?
Well we know if this angle is
50, if this angle is 60, what
is this angle right
here going to be?
Well these three angles are
going to have to add up to 180
as well, right?
So 180 minus 50 is 130
minus 60 is 70.
So this angle is 70 degrees.
And now if I were to draw this a
little bit bigger, it'd look
something like this where this
is A, this is D, this is F.
I'm just drawing this
triangle right here.
And so this is 75, this is
70, and so what's this?
Well 180 minus 70 minus
75 is what?
That's 180 minus
180 minus 145.
And so that should be 35
degrees, and that is choice B.
I will see you in
the next video.
And the important thing to
realize, this is just the
angle game, which I've
made videos on.
And you just have to keep saying
oh, the angles of the
triangle add up to 180, or
there's supplementaries to
that after 180, or you just have
to remember that if the
sides are equal, then the
base angles are equal.
And then you can figure them out
because you know what the
third angle is.
I'll see you in the
next video.